this is howard stern going off on joe
rogan what because of the well he says
anti-vax views but
he just doesn't like the way that joe
rogan talks about the vaccine
this is the only time howard's been
relevant the past 10 years so congrats
that you're back in the headlines
uh but this house stup but this how
stupid howard stern is with his stuff he
thinks by getting vaccinated that you're
it's a cure like it like it stops kovit
he's like get vaccinated we can stop
this thing
it it it will subdue
the
if you do get it but it doesn't cure
[ __ ] covet dum-dum so here's i heard
joe rogan saying what are you busting my
balls for i took horse dewormer and a
doctor gave it to me he said well a
doctor would also give you vaccinations
so why take horse dewormer the shock
jock who supports mandatory vaccination
it also has much for all the [ __ ]
in our country we won't get vaccinations
now before i go on you you'll realize
howard stern
this house
scared he was he stayed in his house did
his show from his house refuse to drive
into manhattan
no one's listening to show so he goes we
have no time for idiots in this country
anymore we don't want you we uh we want
you all either go the hospital or stay
home die there with your kovid this guy
oh
take that cure but don't take it but
don't collect our hospital with your
kovid when you finally get it stay home
don't bother with science it's too late
go [ __ ] yourself we just don't have time
for you um we have it so again this
country people forget about disease
it was always it always wasn't like this
you don't get to live to be 80 years old
automatically it's done with science the
reason we live for language because
science
i really
i'm really out of mind to say look if
you didn't get vaccinated you got cold
you don't get get in the hospital you
had the cure and you went take it
he thinks vaccine's the cure but there i
mean there's people
it's not it's not a cure dumb dumb it's
not a cure
you're more likely to get it if you get
the best so there is one thing no no
that's not true that's absolutely not
true but but um so there's like
everything i've read said you're more
likely to get it if you get the
vaccination
yeah that's absolutely not true here's
the thing so so it is so the people in
the icu beds and the people that dying
right now statistically are people who
didn't get vaccinated you can look at
all the data that is that is a fact so i
so i think the argument becomes
your taxpayers still have to pay for you
when you don't have insurance and you're
in there and you're now here's the thing
in my opinion also if you
i i believe in maximum personal freedom
and if you take the vaccine you're
protected uh you can still get covered
you can still carry it you can still you
still pass very rarely you still pass
apparently you can still pass it so if
you want to get the vaccine right if you
want to get the vaccine get the vaccine
and and i that's what i think but the
problem with man making it mandatory is
you have to show proof on your phone
now you can be tracked now it's a
vaccine passport and so
it's a very difficult dicey situation it
is
so some people say well that's okay when
it comes to public health
probably i am a pro-vaccine i get it but
i also improve freedom and i do think
we're in a very dangerous slippery slope
how much freedom do we lose over this
war on terror where everywhere you go
and you know this from your recent
experience everywhere you go you're on
video oh yeah everywhere you go you're
on video
that's fine until the wrong people get
in power and start using that against
you yeah that's always been historically
the problem but but also and i have no
idea the statistics but rogan had covet
right so the antibodies that you build
up of having coveted is better than the
vaccine there are
science factors there's a lot of
scientists suggest that yes there's a
lot of science yes that that and that's
the that's not
political that is what a lot of
scientists are saying for sure
right so we have to be open and honest
also about that because then what
happens if a guy this and howard didn't
think like this because he's a soy boy
what happens if
you got covid and you have the
antibodies so and let's say you got
covered two months ago but you have the
antibodies and then you go into the
hospital for undisclosed reason they
grow your vaccine you go no and
according to his his theory they turn
you away because you're not vaccinated
but i have the antibodies what are you
talking about dude i'm good but i didn't
get vaccinated because i chose not to
and i'm here for a different reason but
i'm not vaccinated you can turn that
person away well it's america you
[ __ ] do you want better though so so
now you're able to track it on your
phone
so
they can also track if they want it they
can track when you're around somebody
who hasn't been vaccinated so that means
that that could put you so with now
you're traveling
overseas and they get that information
on their computer and they say you've
been exposed somebody wasn't vaccinated
you can't go on this trip or you've got
to go and get a negative contest because
you might be carrying anyway so all of a
sudden all of a sudden you being around
you being around somebody who's not
vaccinated is a liability it could even
in fact it can even affect whether or
not you get to stay at a certain private
hotel maybe rent a place for a month
maybe an airbnb these this is how
you start developing this idea of social
credit score this is what's happening in
china in china you're always tracked
with facial recognition
technology that is here now and the
question is how much of your freedom do
you want to lose in the name of public
safety that is a question yeah dude how
much how about arnold said [ __ ] your
freedom
like holy [ __ ] yeah it's it's a really
interesting debate here in this country
with it my feeling always goes back to
the fact that if i believe in vaccines i
believe in science and i i'm going to do
it but me too but if you but
but if i'm vaccinated and you're not
that's on youtube do your thing that's
what i say do your thing i don't give a
[ __ ] do your thing man that was your
decision i don't care i'm back then i'm
taking care of myself and if i get
covered i'll be less likely to die
and if you get coven odds are you're
gonna be okay too but if you end up
worse off that's you man that's the same
way about lockdowns my daughter for all
you [ __ ] people you know my daughter
was alone in her room
learning school virtually at 12 years
old in her room okay so [ __ ] you what
what what instead of lockdowns i i would
have loved to have seen us say okay we
know that this virus does discriminate
it does discriminate discriminates
against people who are very overweight
uh and old people underlying health
conditions all those people are worthy
of protecting and and i don't want any
sweden did that right so what you do is
you go if you're in a high risk category
you need to stay home and let's figure
this out until we get a vacation maybe
don't go around don't shut down
everybody's [ __ ] business my problem
was health bureaucrats who have nothing
to lose and don't pay any price for
being wrong shut down people's
businesses that they took 30 years to
build and unless you've done that unless
you've been an entrepreneur unless you
have a business and you rely on that
stuff in a marketplace you don't
appreciate what it is and you have no
idea what they've lost so i don't like
when people who don't pay a price for
being wrong and don't pay a price for
policy make policy i got a problem with
that and all of us should that's not
good that's what we're dealing with man